the film's first stop was the Indonesian
island of Borneo home of one of the
world's largest wild orangutan
populations Borneo is very very remote
and we had to take 30,000 pounds of
production equipment upriver on small
boats into the jungle the IMAX crew made
this journey because the world renowned
primatologist dr. Berube mary galdikas
offered them rare access to her work of
studying and saving orangutans 40 years
ago
there were no roads no telephones that
was rich like no electricity you see
what it is that she had to deal with you
know it was swamps the leeches the
insects the heat the humidity I mean
this is one of the most uncompromising
places that I've ever been and she came
here back in the early 70s and built 80
kilometers of trail system to get you
know her deepest jungles of Borneo and
pioneered from nothing this whole study
of orangutan back then they weren't that
habituated so they peed loose spots up
into trees and to walk through everyday
through the rainforest how dense it is
to study these spots up into trees
was not only daunting monumental I think
what attracted me to other towns was
their eyes they have a certain kind of
calmer sweet serenity you come here and
here you are in this amazing forest
that's been preserved and it's
exhilarating because you step off the
boat onto the dock and immediately you
start seeing orangutangs you know coming
over forests almost to say hello
it's magical right here in this paradise
orangutans are under enormous pressure
from palm oil plantations huge tracts of
tropical rainforests specially Warnie
are being leveled to make way for palm
oil plantation obliterating orangutan
habitat and deranged our population is
just getting smaller and smaller every
day I really love around the towns I
think we have a very strong
responsibility to make sure they don't
go extinct and the only way we can do
that is by saving the horse